[Music]
a
let's talk about our democracy for a
minute but let's do it in a way that
makes the snowflakes heads explode let
me be clear before this podcast begins
we are loud proud and do not give a [__]
this is the Tony Michaels podcast real
and raw political and social commentary
the freedom to oppress the rights of
other people is not Liberty you [__]
eating [__] ah the smell of freedom of
speech this is the Tony Michaels podcast
and this is Tony
Michaels hey Tony [__]
[Music]
them
what a [__]
loser I mean yeah I'm talking about
Nikki Haley
but I'm
also talking about Donald Trump he's
still a [__]
loser so I was right about Ronda santz I
was
correct about rad damama
ding-dong I was correct about Nikki
Haley and I will be correct about Donald
Trump now these are not hard things to
see and understand the
media is coming around to the truth this
morning coming around to the way of the
guy
whose motto is [__] them they're coming
around to it this
morning finally
eventually listen
this isn't a bad thing folks I I know a
lot of people are like oh my God this
means there's a chance he could be
president again well not if we [__]
do our
job
okay this is what democracies do is dunk
fascist in
trash over and over and over again if we
have
to
it's what we'll do uh some folks are
pointing out that I was also
correct about Biden yes I was correct
about Biden he's going to win even
though it's Ryden overwhelmingly people
like Biden they're just not
cultist people who who who want
stability and who appreciate decency
don't go around [__] acting like
they're a Jesus or A God they don't
because Joe isn't one he isn't a messiah
he isn't our
Messiah he's just a dude who ran for
president and he happened to be the best
one in 2020 to run for president and we
did that in a primary and he's the
president now he's the incumbent so
we're gonna reelect him for another four
years is he old sure yeah he's [__]
old he's 81 duh where the [__] have you
been yes
hello does that matter no it doesn't
[__] matter there's much more things
more important than the number that that
is behind Joe Biden's age
count and it is clear last night in New
Hampshire because several people have
pointed out to me on Twitter you snarky
little bastards yeah I I get you know
these leftists who think I'm a [__]
loudmouth who don't like me who don't
appreciate Tony Michaels because he
sounds like a righty I don't give a [__]
what do I give a [__] look listen we are
trying to save our [__] democracy
here and you nitpicking how I sound I
don't and frankly it's the [__] them guy
I don't give a [__] call me a loudmouth
I I'm proudly a loudmouth okay that's
what the [__] I do where the [__] have
you been pluck your head out of your ass
the left needs to have a loud mouth the
left needs a mouthpiece and I'm it I'm
it there's no one else that's going to
do it the way that I do it how I do it
as loud as I [__] do it and be able
to say the [__] that I want to say and
the way it needs to be [__] said [__]
them that's just the pure simple [__]
facts that's the
facts and I don't give a [__] I don't
give a [__] who it makes mad I don't
care if you don't [__] like me I
don't care
I don't give a
[__] there is much much more there are
many more things more important than how
people are viewing
me we got [__] to do here folks we got a
[__] country to save from Fascism and
white Christian nationalism and America
First
Nazis we got [__] to do
and we cannot stand around acting
like well you can't say that and you
can't say that that loud that's
ridiculous what do I give a [__] what
should you give a [__]
for listen we are GNA beat the pants off
Donald Trump I believe after last night
seeing the numbers coming out of last
night I believe Joe Biden will beat
Donald Trump by 15 million votes in New
Hampshire in a primary in a Democratic
primary where Joe Biden wasn't even on
the ballot gets more votes than Donald
Trump think about that for a
second think about that for a
second Joe Biden is gonna beat Donald
Trump by 15 million votes in the general
election 15
million because it's obvious it's
obvious that Donald Trump voters has
walked away from him since he became a
[__] traitor and a cou plotter and a
[__] treasonous piece of [__] for
stealing our documents and possibly
selling our top secret
information
but it's up to us to get that 15 million
margin it is up to
us we will not get that 15 million
margin if we stand around arguing about
[__] that and being distracted by [__]
that we don't need to be distracted
by we have to have one narrative and one
message going forward because I again I
told you my optimism at the top of the
ticket
is is very strong I mean I'm sitting
here saying 15 million do you know what
that means 15 million votes that means
Joe Biden doubles his margin from the
last election where he stomped Trump's
ass by eight million
votes there is huge optimism last night
coming out of New Hampshire for our
democracy but we still have to do the
work we have to do the work that's how
it's going to work that's how it's going
to manifest to our democracy staying
put we have we have to do the work and
yes if it takes me yelling and screaming
into a microphone and pushing the
narrative and the messaging and pushing
the the mainstream media to pick up on
some of this messaging and narrative
fine whatever if if we got a band
together with the Carville
Commandos and the rat [__] Patrol and
other groups out there reach out to
other groups we will band with them in
the pro-democracy Coalition we won't
listen to the Grift and the [__] and
the nonsense and the [__] that the
establishment wants us to say and what
they don't want us to say [__] that [__]
we do not have to listen to the
establishment of what they want us to
say and what they don't we do not and
I'm talking about the Democratic
establish
[__] them [__]
them we got a [__] democracy to
save and they'll be the beneficiary of
it don't worry they'll appreciate it
because they'll be the
beneficiary because the most important
thing and I got Jess Piper on today to
tell you about this the most important
thing is these turnouts in these [__]
States if we get these turnouts in these
states to be as high as they possibly
can be for democracy I'm telling you we
are going to slam dunk some of these
Senate
seats Jess Piper has some great news for
you this morning uh she's going to be on
at the bottom of the hour she's got
great news about the state of Missouri
now I know not everyone's in the state
of Missouri but you should be
enthusiastic about this
news because it's going to be another
loss in the America First
Nazis these cousin [__]
fascist MAA these Trump trump
trumpers it's going to be another loss
in their category and that is the most
important thing we have to have is the
biggest [__] turnout we need to pile
up mountains mountains of votes on top
of these
[__] and now we have one of the
biggest drivers to the polls at the top
of the ticket Donald Trump because
people are going to go vote against
him clip after clip after clip in New
Hampshire last night when they voted for
Nikki Haley it was I'm voting for Nicki
Haley because of I'm voting against
Donald Trump American Americans vote
against stuff that's how it [__]
works here in the great country of
America we vote against stuff and the
and the Republican Party ensured last
night ured it for us now I've been
saying it for a long time I knew this
was going to happen right but now it's
official Tony was
correct just like on March 4th it'll be
official Tony's correct on February 9th
when they decide to kick the 14th and go
[__] yourself he's going to be on
ballots Tony will be right
again it's not hard to know these things
it really isn't it really isn't and to
beg and plead for some one person or one
one one panel judges to save our country
that's the stupidest [__] thing I've
ever heard of in my life that's the
dumbest [__] we are democracy we are a
constitutional Democratic
Republic that is what we are that is our
form of government we should respect it
we should appreciate it and we should do
the actual work to save
it not count on some prosecutor or some
[__]
judge [__] that [__] or some Secretary
of State [__] that [__] I'm not going to
stand around and wait on them to save
our democracy we are going to do this
[__] just like they did last night in
New
Hampshire Dean Phillips is all excited
he got he got double digits dude you
were on the ballot and you got your ass
kicked by a guy who's 81 who's feeble
who's not going to win who's not going
to beat Donald Trump that's what Dean
Phillips keeps
saying you got your ass stomped man
so keep it up and really frankly I'm
excited that Dean Phillips may stay in
the race and I'm excited that Nikki
Haley may stay in the race spin that
Republican money [__] hails to the yeah
I hope Dean Phillips and Nikki Haley
stay into the [__] convention and
they spend hundreds of millions of
dollars of Republicans
money every [__] month every [__]
week all the way up till the very end
[__] them spend that telling me there's
a
chance spend that
money [__]
him just like Ronda santz I'm sad that
Ronda santz is
out and his money well went dry I'm
really man that disappoints me a lot I
was hoping Ronda santis would stay in
and keep spending that [__]
money that they would spend on Trump
otherwise because they're all going to
go to
Trump oh yeah Nikki Haley after South
Carolina after getting beaten by 70
points and her [__] home state will
drop out that night if she makes it that
far we're talking about a month from now
now there is a reality here that I want
that I want to tell you about and the
reality is is that the Republican donors
know that Donald Trump is toast not only
is he going to lose this election but
his ass is going to [__]
prison he's going to be convicted on
these [__] f now how they actually
incarcerate him I guess that's a good
[__] question for another year so
we're not even going to get into that
[__]
postulation at this
point but the Republican donor class
know that Donald Trump is [__] toast
the problem is is that the problem they
created is they created a cult and they
made him the cult leader and they didn't
understand that they weren't going to be
able to rip the cult away from a guy who
won't shut the [__]
up
and that's the most important part
folks and his delusion is
delicious he really believes this [__]
that he can win because people around
him have kept saying it in his ear yeah
you can win sure you can win oh there's
no one else that can beat Joe Biden
besides you in all kinds of [__] lies
and
[__] just sticking it up his ass and
sticking it up his ass and sticking it
up his
ass oh yeah they love the [__] him
there's no there's because they get to
grift off them someone posted a picture
of Alina Haba next to a pool you know
you know in a swimsuit or whatever and
they thought she looked sexy which you
know I'm not saying she doesn't she
looks [__] hot she looks like she
could suck a mean dick I'm not going to
lie those [__] dsls are on
point with Alina hampa
and they were saying that oh look look
at Trump's lawyer Eat Your Heart Out
Biden and I was like what eat your heart
out he's happily [__] married and he
is not indicted on 91 felonies so why
would Joe Biden give a [__] about alinaa
habba and Alina habba has [__]
fleeced $ two and a half million dollars
away from Trump because she's got a nice
rack and she's got nice dsls and he
thinks she's smart because she'll say
whatever the [__] she has to say to get
his
money the [__] out of here she's a
courtroom [__] that's right I said it
and we need to we need to stop this [__]
where people get offended well I'm
offended by what you say you can't say
that about her she's a woman I don't
give a
[__] we have to get [__] tough here
folks and we have to lean into this [__]
we can't back on this our [__]
country depends on this
[__] and yeah yeah I I get it I get it a
lot of people don't want to say that
[__] out loud but someone's got to
[__] say that [__] out loud gets down
here then that will be all all this this
[__] that you think is so important
you can just kiss all that
goodbye and listen if I'm the one that
has to do it fine fine I'll do it I'll
be the voice out front I'll be the rodeo
clown I don't give a
[__] can't [__] cancel the [__]
guy
anyways
cancel a [__] him guy what
the he says [__] him [__] you you can't
cancel the [__] up guy try
it but it's time we get tough It's time
we punch
back because we got down ballot races to
win we got referendums to [__]
win this country depend depends on it
again the top of the ticket is going to
be easy folks that's that's the easiest
[__] race we got to win is Biden vers
Trump last night it's clear Biden is
gonna Stomp the ever loving [__] out of
Donald Trump he's gonna take him behind
the Woodshed pull his [__] pants down
and beat his ass with a
2x4 with Nails in it you know because
it's
brutal
it's going to be a
bloodbath but we cannot count we cannot
count on these people just just
overwhelmingly know that they need to
vote for anyone who vote against anyone
who is even even just has the just the
[__] just the stench of MAA oh oh you
got an our next your name man you smell
like a [__] Nazi to
me oh oh you you you're you're touting
white Christian nationalist talking
points smells like a [__] Nazi to
me I don't give a [__] if they're
running for dog
catcher I don't give a [__] if they're
running for city council the road
district the state representative State
Senate Governor United State Senator
you're your your us house rep I don't
give a [__] which race it is
if that
stench of Maga or white Christian
nationalism if it smells like a Nazi
it's a [__] Nazi
period vote against
it and that's what we got to get this
turnout to
understand that the disease is not Trump
he is the symptom of the disease the
only way to get rid of him and these
[__] MAA slugs
is to vote every single [__] one of
them out of our
governments use the power of your ballot
to show this to show this nation to show
the world that we are not [__] white
Christian nationalists we are not MAA we
are not Nazis and we will not [__]
tolerate that [__] here we do not
tolerate
intolerance no [__] way no [__]
how not today not yesterday not tomorrow
not ever we will not tolerate
intolerance and I don't give a [__] who
your intolerance is for I don't care if
it's against black and brown people the
lgbtq community Li tards I don't give a
[__] my intolerance is the
intolerant I'm sick of the [__] we
should be sick of the [__] and we should
dunk this [__] in the [__]
trash in this country and we should use
our our power of our ballot to do it it
is the proper way that democracies get
rid of fascism it really
is protest
assembly vote protest assembly vote
protest assembly vote that's what
[__] democracies
do and that is how our our great
Democratic constitutional republic is
set
up and we should use every single one of
our rights all the way up to to the
[__]
line all the way up to it I don't care
if we have to mock them I don't care if
we have to make fun of them I don't care
if we have to call them names I don't
care if we have to get down in the mud
with them I don't give a [__] I don't
think there is nothing I may not say to
save this country into this microphone I
just don't believe that there's anything
I may not say to save this country into
this
microphone and if you don't like that if
that makes me a loud mouth well great
good
good it's time to fight for our
democracies the way that we should we
should band together we should form
actual coalitions public
alliances get through the
[__] stop talking about polls stop
talking about oh right look at the
numbers here let me show you my let me
show you my voting board
let me let me show you how I don't know
what the [__] I'm talking
about Jesus Christ Steve karaki on MSNBC
has t been talking about the 2008 race
listen to what I'm saying the 2008 race
for for [__]
weeks to give analysis on New Hampshire
and Iowa what in the actual [__] are you
talking about we are not in the same
[__] normal we are not in the same
[__] timeline is
2008 pluck your head out of your [__]
asses and understand the
stakes it's time we get to the real
[__] truth and the real [__] truth
is is manga's lost and that's okay
they're lost they got brain worms and
the worms have finished their [__]
meal they ain't got enough brain cells
to rub together to create a [__]
party in this country the Republican
party is dead DEA dead and they are
bearing it in their grave and we should
not should not could not would not and
won't take the shovel out of their hands
as they bury the Republican party for
[__] good [__] them let them nominate
that treasonous piece of [__] let them
nominate that [__] traitor that
[__] coup plotter the goddamn [__]
doc our top secret document seller that
[__]
grifter that smelly ass fat [__] [__]
them let them pick him let them put him
on those [__] ballots [__] him and
[__] the gqp it's time we show them who
the [__] we are and how we [__] turn
out and let's send a [__] message and
and it doesn't have to stop just at this
year folks when we form this Coalition
and we form this new attitude on the
left I'm telling you this will [__]
Cascade into
2026 it'll Cascade into 2028 2030 2032
this will Cascade from state to state to
state and it won't stop why do you think
they're terrified of someone like me and
I don't mean the right why do you think
the left is terrified of someone like me
they're terrified of it God if they let
loose the messaging if they let loose
and this takes all my God then they
won't The Establishment won't control
what you're supposed to be offended by
what you're supposed to say and how
you're supposed to say it how the [__]
do you think we're gonna
win how in the [__] do you think we're
going to win without a message and a
narrative that the American people will
[__] vote vote
for
but we have to make sure fascism is at
Bay before we move on to the most
important
things but we can form a message and a
narrative at a 50,000 foot level that
will Cascade down to local races that
will make sure that your communities are
safe that will ensure that your public
schools your
hospitals the social safety net stays
intact
and we can do it all all by ourselves we
do not need anyone to [__] help us we
don't need any super pack we don't need
no [__] organization we don't need
any of them we can do it all on our own
as a pro-democracy
coalition and I'm asking you and I am
asking you to join in on operation go
commando and our first Target in
operation go
commando is to attract carville's
Commandos to the [__] fam to the rat
Army to the meme Legion and create
digital digital Legions of people who
can and will March forward in our
democracy I'm telling
you this democracy is not about a
president this democracy is not about a
candidate in any one party this
democracy is not about the US Senate or
the Congress a governor
an attorney general a state house your
County Commission the [__] road
district this democracy is about the
people and last night the people proved
in New
Hampshire and gave a foreshadowing what
the hell is to come in
November and it is so important it is so
important that we use every single bit
every single ounce of messaging and
narrative that we have at our disposal
to get this turnout to be the biggest
turnout in
history these down ballot races are so
important we must make inroads in these
states we must make inroads in the US
Senate and we must take the house back
and we must we must make sure that every
single referendum around the country
that ensures and enshrines people's
rights into those States constitutions
have those voters there to pile
mountains of [__] votes on top of
these fashist
white Christian nationalism is
here and I'm telling you it is the
disease Trump is only the
symptom this lives in your [__]
States this lives in your counties this
lives in your school boards I don't care
what state you live in it is there and
they are ready to pounce to take away
your parental rights take away your
rights to Health Care make pregnancy
criminal CRI IE what you're dressed as
who you
love and they won't stop
there they will not stop there it is so
important that our message is on point
and that we drive people to the
polls not just for that top ticket
because again folks I'm very optimistic
we are going to beat the [__] pants
off the poopy pants off Grandpa Hitler
we are going to whip his
ass but it is so important that we drive
in these states these turnouts and we
shall not shut up and we shall not be
silent we shall be loud and proud and
I'm gonna I brought someone on today to
show you how to do it she's got great
news in the state of Missouri speaking
of referendums great news in the state
of Missouri I can't wait to talk to her
about this I know this is near and dear
to her heart Jess Piper is going to join
us right after this break don't go
anywhere go have some pizza this
commercial always makes me
hungry we'll be right back Mark 60
seconds this is the Tony Michaels
[Music]
podcast are you ready for best pizza of
Life bring friends down to pepperoni hug
spot our chefs make pizza with heart and
special touch cheese pepperoni vegetable
and more secret things need delivery
pizzas come fast knock knock who's there
pizza magic eat pepperoni hug spot Pizza
your tummy say thank you your mouth say
m pepperoni hug spot it's like family
but with more
cheese catch Tony's twitch stream the
[__] list Roundup at
twitch.tv/ thony Michaels we're back to
the king of Brilliance this is the Tony
Michaels
[Music]
podcast pizza pizza pizza pizza love
that AI commercial we've got a new
sponsor for you today we previewed it
yesterday it's Grand tias Grand tias ice
cream shop grandus ice cream shop has
the best ice cream on the Block because
well because it's anti-fascist ice cream
that's right white supremacists are
allergic to this type of ice cream in
these cookies at Granda ice cream shop
don't forget to visit your local
granda's ice cream shop where where
Granda makes the best ice cream on the
Block no we don't serve vanilla there's
just we don't serve vanilla at the
umega ice cream shop oh boy you know I'm
for the fake grifts I'm for the fake
griffs it happens we gotta we got to
play around we got to be we got to have
fun here let me show you the actual
grift here here's the actual grift it's
free you just go to the Tony
michaels.com hit subscribe at the top of
the page it doesn't cost you a single
nickel and then you pan on down to
patreon that's right you can follow me
on patreon for free you can buy a
membership there if you wish it helps
keep this microphone powered on against
fascism but it is free to follow me
there also it's free to join the Discord
server and you're actually going to want
to join the book club on the Discord
server too so both of those links are
there if you want to get involved in the
book club sponsored by the library of
democracy over there on the Discord
server so check that out it's also free
if you link your Amazon Prime account to
your Twitch account you get one free
subscription on Twitch with your Amazon
Prime account and if you have done that
before you got to go back in and
resubscribe it it doesn't cost you a
single thing so they're free griffs
they're absolutely they're free so it's
kind of a shitty Griff but you know
that's how it goes um in the land of
content creat now if you want to get in
on the team tattoo this Friday so a
couple more days I'm getting the the
this machine kills fascist microphone
tattooed on my arm that's right and I'll
be live streaming so if you want to see
me in pain just go to the team tattoo
fund I want to tell you that I am so I
am so happy so many people have gone
into the fund all the money that goes
into this is going to go to the artist
so whether it's ink or time or tip it's
all going to go to the artist every
single bit of it um so go to Team tattoo
fund you'll be first on the list I'll
get your email from and if you've done
an anonymous a lot of people have
wondered if you do an anonymous one it's
okay you can do Anonymous one I still
get your email you'll still be on the
list um to get the link for the live
streams to see me in some sort of pain I
think that's what you're actually
wanting I think that's why people are
contributing to this is so you can see
me in pain so go to the Tony
michaels.com click the team tattoo fund
if you want to see the me in pain
getting my tattoo live streamed I don't
know if she's got tattoos or not but
this show this show is the only
political show that feels like it has
tattoos and does drugs so it is the
thing Jess Piper I am so glad you're
back here how are you my friend I'm
doing well I do not do drugs but I do
have tattoos
oh what where where where is your best
tattoo where's the best they're girl
they're girly tattoos I have that's good
that's that's okay that's okay I have
Walt Whitman tattooed on my arm and I
have a couple on my feet um I had a
Jesus fish from when I was 19 and oh
yeah it's now covered over with a
mountainscape oh okay so so so you came
came to the conclusion that the Jesus
fish sent the wrong message is that what
you're saying it didn't represent me as
a person anymore so yeah well you know
sometimes we change in life I've made a
lot of changes since I was a young young
lad and I had a lot of experience in
life and you know I think I think
sometimes people have enough brain cells
to realize that their experiences they
should open up their their ears and
their mind mind and take these
experiences and like carry them with
them and you know just discover am I
making the right decisions do I think
the right way today is yesterday's
thinking something that should be gone
and today's thinking should be something
that I should be um promoting so I
appreciate change especially for white
rule folks like us you know what I mean
exactly and you know changing your mind
doesn't mean anything other than you've
had some growth and so I don't know why
people are always so scared to say well
IED used to believe this but then I did
this and and my beliefs have evolved um
and that's perfectly natural and you're
right that's exactly what happens from
Young adulthood to being an old grandma
like
me well let's let's talk about something
because you have some news now last time
last week you were on here and you said
you're going to have some news for us um
now that news has has dropped since it's
been almost a week but give us give the
audience an idea of what's going on in
Missouri and why it is so important well
um we finally had an IP um ballot
language approved so that we can put
abortion on the ballot and um there's an
organization and maybe you could link
that um for your listeners where you can
sign up um and hopefully they'll have
the petitions ready to go and to sign
very soon so we are moving that's great
yeah I know but you know what's
happening um in retaliation for that
right go ahead they're going to change
the they're trying to change the IP um
the way we we get things on the ballot
So currently in Missouri um IP allowed
us to get medical what it tell tell the
audience what IP is initiative petition
so that means when our lawmakers aren't
doing what we want them to do and we're
going to go ahead and put things on the
ballot ourself that's a petition and so
to get something past like recreational
weed mariju um you know medical uh
expanded medicaid uh we be back right to
work with all these things and what it
did is it put it on the ballot and a
simple majority would you know get the
things we wanted got all those things
normally known as a referendum that you
call that a lot and we've seen a lot of
these we see this we've seen this in
Ohio recently um we' seen it in Kentucky
uh MI Michigan um we've seen it in
Kansas and other states even red States
overwhelmingly these these referendums
have gone in the way of women's rights
to healthc care and not criminalizing
pregnancies um because that's one thing
that I think Americans don't want is to
criminalize pregn pregnancies and ban
women's privacy in doctor's offices I
mean that's right so in every one of
these states every one of the GOP um you
know elected folks have decided they're
going to try to change the rules and but
in Missouri and like I always say the
GOP reminds me of like AI it just throws
[__] on the wall and they see what works
and what doesn't work and then they
change their behavior right right and so
they they saw Ohio that what they said
is no more uh simple majorities you have
to get 57% of the people in your state
to vote for this for it to become and
Ohioans were like hell no and they voted
that down and then they voted to give
women you know bodily autonomy but
Missouri GOP politicians paid attention
so this is what they're doing and it
sounds very confusing because it is so
right now it's a simple majority right
and the GOP wants to change it to this
as simple majority in the majority of
the house districts so that will raise
the level of folks who need to vote for
this by thousands thousands of
signatures right you're going to have
some places in Missouri that are
absolutely not going to vote for you
know to give women bodily autonomy so
they're taking away one person one vote
they're taking away majority rule and
they're doing that because they know
abortion will pass in Missouri right and
they're not going to stop they're not
going to stop at Women's Healthcare
right that's not that's not where
they're going to stop I mean I I've I've
even heard ground Rumblings um from some
of these white Christian nationalists
and that's what this is um this is white
Christian nationalism uh full stop when
they're trying to rig the game because
they know that they can't win the game
because the the majority of the people
in a state don't want their policies and
they're the policy makers you know
they're trying to rig the game so they
can rule over us um but we see the
ground Rumblings even um on Charlie Kirk
show especially on Nick flintz his
America first uh um shows and his
streams that they're they're wanting to
take the vote away from women I think
that's where the speaking of Missouri
and the Kansas City Chiefs that's where
they um that's where they really been uh
trying their best to get people really
angry at Taylor Swift for doing nothing
other than posting an Instagram post
with a link to a register to vote site
um and and it's because they know that
young women are the majority of Taylor
Swift's followers the swifties and they
know that if young women register to
vote young women are going to I don't
know vote for their rights to health
care right make sure that they're they
they're not going to have their
pregnancies criminalized make sure that
they don't it's not their privacy isn't
banned in a doctor's office um I I think
this is um is where they're going is
that they're going to say well women
can't vote because why would they want
the folks to vote when they're trying to
take away the right because it usually
doesn't work like that very well well
when you're taking away people's rights
they don't usually go vote for you to
take away the rights but you know maybe
it's just me no I mean the the problem
with what the Republicans are trying to
do is we already have we we've lived for
51 years with abortion access so when
you take something away that we've had
that's going to cause a ripple effect
and that will cause even Republican
women to say absolutely not this is not
what I meant if we already have folks
who are gay and can be mayed in our
state and people are trying to say no
not anymore every kid that I raised grew
up knowing that gay people could get
married they're offended by this like
why would you do this to people so their
big problem is not just regressive
policies but trying to rip things away
from us that we have always had I am I a
grandmother I'll be 49 um and I had my
children young and you know it is what
it is I'm from Arkansas well we're we're
we're R folks and we have children young
that's I always say I'm from Arkansas
what else was I supposed to do my son
I'm not even 40 my son's gonna graduate
from high school this year so there you
go so see but um Ro was decided before I
was born and I will not I mean I will
not stop because I have daughters I have
two granddaughters you can screw off
with you know coming after us oh you can
say [__] you can say [__] you you're on
the Tony M you get to say whatever you
want you get the most I usually do is
drop a [__] every now and then they bad
no not you know what I mean the word
well I mean you do drop a [__] but you
mean you mean the word the word not the
see got this is going south yeah well
you gotta you gotta have you got have
fun here at the Tony Michaels podcast
that's what we do here so you really do
and I need to say something that's
really important that's happening right
now in Missouri um our favorite U
Senator Nick Shore um is right
nowy yeah in front of um the
flamethrower he's in front of the Senate
right now with a bill to um defund
Planned Parenthood and they always do
this thing but here's the thing Tony you
can't get an abortion in Missouri at
Planned Parenthood Nick's legislation
already did that so now he's defunding
he wants to defund planed Parenthood but
to accept Federal expanded medicaid
dollars you have to fund Planned
Parenthood so he is putting in Jeopardy
four billion with a B $4 billion doll
for nursing homes and hospitals and you
know people were on hospice and disabled
children on the line to defund a clinic
that at this point is only giving poor
women access to STI testings and Pap
smears and affordable birth control and
that's how you know this abortion ban
everything about it was a war against
women because he's still trying to
defund the place that can't give you an
abortion anyway can I tell you a story
about Planned Parenthood sure and it's a
personal story it's it's a personal
story in my family so um my wife had an
IUD and we wanted to have another child
and uh which is a result of my my
daughter who is the most beautiful girl
I've ever seen in my life as you know
that's how dad's feel about their
daughters um but she went to get her IUD
removed so we could actually have our
daughter and she decided to go to the
Planned Parenthood um to have the IUD
removed and the reason why is because it
was the most affordable to have that
procedure done uh safely yeah um and
when she went
they had to have security because she
pulled in the parking lot it's a little
small parking lot she had to pull in and
they had and security came out to escort
her in while people were yelling at her
that she was a baby killer and you know
all this crazy ass [__] unknownst to
them she's going into to the clinic to
have the IUD removed so she can have a
baby not not have a procedure to get rid
of a pregnancy um so and and and or it
had resulted that type of Healthcare
that was funded and my wife gave you
know she paid her part and everyone else
paid their part and that that healthc
care that was funded in that clinic for
her to get that procedure resulted in
our daughter so it was PR if you want to
you know say it like that um so I want
to I want to tell everyone that plant
Parenthood the majority of the services
that they actually give is Women's
Healthcare and it's for the women um
they do provide other services for other
folks um and do give direction to other
other type of services but they provide
Health Care to women is what they do
safely regulated Health Care to make
sure that the woman gets the health care
that they need access to it to safe Safe
Care um so that's just my little story
right that it always gets me when people
think that Planned Parenthood is like
some sort of
slaughterhouse um and when when really
honestly they're giving a lot of
healthcare to make a lot of babies yeah
in the pl like they're giving way more
Health Care in the Planned Parenthood
for women to have babies than to not
have a baby and it's just it's insane to
me that uh but you know these people
want to ban contraception as well not
only do they want to get rid of funding
for that type of Health Care that would
provide health care for women to have
baby safely um which Nick Nick clearly
probably has never actually really talk
to a woman about this he's probably
never actually I would imagine that Nick
has never had an encounter with a woman
where he was interested in what her
experience was with her healthare um and
that's probably Nick's problem um and
you know Nick is an [__] I'll say it
um so I would imagine that he's never
actually listened when a woman would
talk to him at all but especially talk
to him about her personal experience of
her health care and access to it and why
it's important to her and I can tell you
from personal experience that Nick
doesn't understand consent he has he has
a podcast he has a radio show and he had
asked me to come on it and I said um you
know probably not I'd rather not do that
because I have gone on radio shows to
try to speak reasonably um with you mean
right-wing radio shows not like mine
where we're no no no I mean he had a
podcast no he's on the opposite Spectrum
um but I've been on one of these before
and the man talked over me the whole
time and raised his voice so that I
couldn't respond to questions right and
so I was like that's not something I'm
interested in doing or wasting my time
on so I I said no and then I was in
Kansas giving um a speech there was I
don't know 200 people there right before
I go on my phone rings and it's an
unknown number from St Charles so
whatever it went to voicemail and I got
up and spoke did my thing came out and I
listened to the voicemail and it was
Nick on his live show calling me and
then he told everybody she said you know
she agreed that she would do this and I
was like I was at a speaking event I
would never agree to do this and by the
way no no Nick I did not and that's how
that's a minor thing but that's not
understanding consent right Tony he
didn't understand when I told him no
that means no don't contact me and why
how did you get my cell phone number
like how did you that's the creepiest
[__] I've ever heard in my life but no
means no even if it's like do you want
to do this no I do not he doesn't
understand well and I know I know from
experience um dealing with your schedule
you're very busy Bu you're very busy and
that is why when when I when I find a a
very good opportunity to bring you on
because we love having you on here
number one you're way prettier than I am
but the other thing too is that the
audience loves you and they love your
perspective and what I really like about
how your perspective is is that you're
so grounded in these local issues but
really you're able to tie it to the
National messaging um and and really
give folks a sense that everything's
local but it's National because we seen
last night Nikki Haley got stomped in
New Hampshire um and and really the good
news out of New Hampshire is that even
in a right in campaign Joe Biden got
more votes than Donald Trump would ever
dream of getting in New Hampshire at
this point after he's tried to commit a
coup and and he's basically a traitor to
the United States by doing that um but
here's the thing is that Nikki Haley
will never be the nominee for the
Republican Party one reason why is
because she's a woman um the other
reason um why is she pretends to hate
women you know what I mean she pretends
it's not a very good act that she that
she puts on but I want you to tell folks
why this
referendum um in November the petitions
and the referendum in November for
abortion here in Missouri why is it
important to other people in other
states and I think it's the reason why
Nikki Haley keeps saying I want a
National Abortion ban because isn't that
the rub here like Ohio we talked about
earlier Kansas if Missouri does this
isn't it all at risk because they
understand that that the states can
change their constitution up into the
point to where the federal government
says no you can't change your
Constitution anymore so is that what is
at stake here and tell the audience why
it is so important to tie local
messaging and local referendums in
states to this National message because
we have these down ballot races um to
win yeah um I mean all of these things
when people say if you don't like it
moved it's a red State that's what it's
going to be but here's the thing they
are using our red States as playgrounds
to run up legislation and U to scotus
they have you know a free pass to get it
right in front of um a captured court
that is not going to give us what we
need and so by democrats pulling back
and people saying oh it doesn't matter
it's Missouri it doesn't matter it's
Iowa well here's the thing Missouri laws
bleed into into Illinois they bleed into
other states because our uh attorney
generals are going after right now
Missouri's attorney general Bailey is
going after the abortion medication and
he and and several other Red State AGS
are doing this it doesn't stop in the
red State when people said you know none
of this matters because women will still
have access to abortion and then dobs
came through and we realized that that's
not true and um I'll say this about
messaging it's hard to be in a room with
DC Consultants who aren't on the ground
who don't know what's happening who told
me there's no reason to buy yard signs
like yard signs don't vote well no [__]
but you know what I put out a Biden sign
and I have people drive by me all day
long and they're like holy hell she
lives in the middle of nowhere and she's
voting for Biden I feel comfortable now
I feel like I have Community I feel like
there are other people who represent my
values and DC cons Consultants will tell
you every day of the week there's no
reason to do that there's no reason to
run in these areas where you can't win
yes there is it is undemocratic and
quite frankly it's immoral to leave
people in places without a choice and to
say you don't matter enough there's 480
people in your town and you don't matter
enough and that's what we have seen from
National parties and even sometimes from
the state parties and we have to get
over this hump and realize everyone
deserves representation and when you
don't give them representation when you
don't give them a choice you elect
extremists who know that they don't have
to answer to anybody because no one is
going to oppose them they go to Jeff
City they write the craziest most insane
[__] and send that up right and then
other red States see it and they're like
we can do this too and eventually we out
Missouri Missouri and we're out Florida
Florida and we're out Texas Texas that's
what they think speaking of Florida
Today I just you know everyone's rolling
back child labor laws along as as
they're defunding schools and also
making it impossible to have you know
legal immigration so folks can come here
and work so now we're going to rely on
child labor GOP passed a bill through U
Florida committee today to allow 16 and
17 year olds to work 8 hour shifts on a
school night and 30 hours a week and one
of the representatives who was for it
said hey I worked full-time and it's
about time that we take America back and
we do that by allowing children to work
he said those words and so when when we
think of insanity it it is abortion
banss it it is defunded schools it is
child labor
it is not having Access to Health Care
in your communities it is roads that
aren't drivable all of these things are
in interconnected and all of it is meant
to do this to keep us down and I tell
you one more thing that your audience
should know we have lost the meaning of
the word solidarity this is class
solidarity I don't care if you're white
black brown I don't care we come
together and we say you're not going to
do this to us or our children and we
lost that along the way and now they
have you you know invited white rural
folks to join the you know the GOP
because they're Evangelical and I say
don't join the GOP because they're
against you and you know it you're
living in a single wide trailer friend
they don't care about you this is about
coming together you know as communities
this is solidarity it should be it
should be and it should be solidarity
against the bastardization of the
Evangelical and the Christian religion
in that white Christian nationalist
white Christian nationalism is
definitely
uh the vehicle that they're using to
push their authoritarianism because as
you talked about before they know they
can't win with the people they know they
can't win with with against these votes
and against these people voting for
their own rights and against them taking
their rights away from them and so in
that in that move they are using white
Christian nationalism to walk towards
authoritarianism it is the reason why
Donald Trump is going to be their
nominee it is the reason why we are
going to have fascist slugs all around
the country toing toing MAA toning
buckets of Maga around in their races in
these Senate races these house races
States races and I'm telling you I'm
telling you it's going to get to it's
going to get to a point um to where
people are going to snap and I and I
think that's starting to happen we we
there was a lot of footage yesterday out
of New Hampshire where a lot of these
Haley uh Nikki Haley vot voters were
Trump voters like two times before 16
and 20 and like no I'm voting for Haley
because I'm voting against Trump I don't
like Haley I don't like I'm just voting
against Trump um and I think we're going
to see that all across the country and I
think if we get the pro-democracy
Coalition and we call it operation go
commando here I don't know if you saw
carville's video about the Carville
Commandos we're trying to recruit
Carville to come over here to the to the
to the [__] them fam and uh to to to to
the Tony Michaels podcast and and create
a coalition um because I think you're
right the establishment and the
Democratic establishment they're getting
better but they're not there yet to
really to really make sure we pile
mountains of votes on top of this down
ballot races um and we got to get the
candidates we got to get the candidates
so so tell everyone where to find Jess
Piper to get those candidates in
Missouri and how to do it in other
states because it's a great example tell
us where the audience should find you
please go to Blu missouri. org and think
about being a member there I mean 10
bucks and and from thousands of people
it's going to make a huge difference in
down ballot candidate budgets in
Missouri
100% of your donation goes to a
candidate I'm paid out of a different
fund you can leave a tip for me you
don't have to leave a tip for me it's on
the up and up I hate scams and all that
crap so it really does go to the
nominees and I talk to the nominees and
it really does make a difference so Blu
missouri. org um on Facebook you know uh
Twitter and Instagram I'm Piper from
Missouri and on Tik Tok I'm just Piper
Mo um and you can always just uh Google
my name and find out that I'm a CRT
teacher um
that I love Dei that I'm a Marxist and
um all the yeah you're you're you're one
of them red Kami folks right right well
it's good it's good because I broad I
know you're broadcasting from Missouri
but I broadcast here at the antifa
headquarters
in I don't know if you know where
commies Falls Missouri hits but that's
where we're at we're at the end yeah I'm
interested that sounds like a great
place to vacation you should come to
commi Falls and hang out sometimes it's
it's it's all kinds of marxist here
there's socialists there's there's
libtards running out the mayor is a
libtard for crying out loud here in
commi Falls Missouri so Jess I
appreciate you coming and I appreciate
you joking with this but I appreciate
your seriousness about your democracy um
because we we need you in this fight and
we have you in this fight I know um
because you're not going to give up on
this no matter what what what soy boy
Nick says um in uh in St Louis isn't it
funny how he tries to be all kind
country and he's from St Louis isn't
that funny I love it I love it I know I
always I mean it's cosplay and that's
why they always have a hard time with me
and why they attack me because I am what
they say they are I really am right
right I I grew up on a farm there son I
grew up at dut and cattle and stuff all
right we we we plk the heads off
chickens yeah Mountain Oysters man yeah
hell yeah hell yeah have you ever been
to the oan testical Festival the testy
festy you've never been to the testy
festy no they're so rich I mean I grew
up eating them they're so rich I can
only take you know half a
ball all right well I guess I guess
we'll end we'll end on half of bald then
Jess Piper everyone go follow Jess Piper
and it one more time give the org
the.org it's blue missouri. yeah blue
missouri. org we'd love to have you um
we have monthly meetings and we visit
and we talk about stuff like this right
here so yeah well Blu missouri. org and
go follow Jess everywhere everyone Jess
Piper the fighter in democracy she's a
soldier everyone stick around we'll be
right back right after
this we'll be right back Mark 60 seconds
this is the Tony Michaels
[Music]
podcast are you numb and alone after
storming the capital have you been left
out in the cold after stealing Nancy P's
mail do you feel exposed to a govern
that doesn't share your patriotic values
if any of these describe you then you're
in luck hi I'm Paul gosar in thanks to
my new product part and blanket I've got
you covered part and blanket
specifically Works to make you feel safe
and cozy after your involvement on
January 6th and if you're one of the
other members of Congress who also
helped with the attempted coup hard and
blanket will protect you too paron
blanket is made of a sort of soft fleece
and a layer of sheep's wool and and
they're 100% made in the USA don't delay
and get your pardon blanket today for
just
$999.99 actual pardon not
guaranteed jumping back into it this is
the Tony Michaels
podcast welcome back to the show welcome
back to the show Jeff
Piper a true Fighter for democracy she
don't give a [__] what the establishment
says she's going to do her thing and
she's going to get people elected it's a
great example for anyone in a red state
that would like to help in the alfor of
getting people on the ballot in the down
ballot races so that people have a
choice because that's one thing that
Jess um not only does she focus in on
the school vouchers um and women's
rights to health care but she also
focuses in on those down ballot races so
that so that people who want to vote for
a Democrat have a Democrat to vote for
because a lot of times in a rural State
like I live in and she lives in and some
of you live in you don't have the
ability to vote for a Democrat because
there's no one running um because they
don't have the money to run or the
support to run or even the knowledge of
the support to run and we have to give
these people the ability and the
knowledge to do that so go to Blu
missouri. org follow Jess everywhere I'm
telling you it's worth it just just to
get a sense of her messaging because she
is an expert an expert at making the
national narrative all pen down to the
to the to the local type races and the
local type messaging she does such a
great job at it um she's so good at it
all right I got a few comments I want to
get to here flea bag Boogie says Tony
must not like me he doesn't talk like a
sailor in front of a lady what I told
her she could say the word [__] I told
her she could say the word [__] and we
were talking about eating
nuts come on what are you talking about
I don't think I don't think um Jess
Piper spring proper do you she's kind of
country to me you know just saying
thanks for your comment thanks for your
comment flea bag Boogie Mel Welker says
rather see Hell Sparks all right I okay
go go watch hell I don't know I don't
know I don't know what to tell you I
mean I guess I'm I'm the only one on
right now [__] out I don't know I mean I
I would like to watch Hal too I don't
have enough time to watch Hal I was on
Hal's show a few weeks ago maybe I
should maybe I should get Hal back on
this show that way Mel Mel can have a
little taste of Tony and
Hal I don't know
maybe oh boy oh
boy oh boy H great women say [__] I
almost bet Jess Piper says [__] she just
probably doesn't like to get caught on
camera saying [__] maybe Pam I don't
know I tried she almost said it didn't
she maybe I should make that a goal to
get Jess Piper to say the word [__] into
a microphone I don't
know oh boy oh
boy I guess Hal just signed off till
later today I don't know sure
great we're here every every weekday
Monday through Friday new Eastern 11
Central 9 Pacific and boy do we have an
ask for you I got a great ask for you I
want you to join operation go commando
that's Operation go commando you can see
the art that the skip is has developed
here always punch Nazis I mean that that
that pretty much sounds it out you know
what I mean um but operation go commando
we are trying to court other coalitions
uh to join the [__] them fam I think we
can do
this I think we can do
this court other I mean obviously you
know we're playing off the carville's
Commandos because I I just think I just
think that James carville's brand fits
the [__] them fam brand so well you know
what I mean I think it fits like
perfectly Carville definitely fits in
here at the Tony Michaels podcast right
right and especially now that he's going
full mockery and he don't give a [__]
and he definitely does not give a [__]
what the establishment saying or how
they're going to do it he even said in
the video we got a [__] democracy to
save okay I don't give a [__] anymore
basically [__] them right [__] them [__]
them and that you know I want to go back
to that real quick cuz that phrase [__]
them and really if you want a [__] them
sticker you can get one just like this
you go to Tony
michaels.com hit the Ted Cruz uh merch
and you'll be taken to the sticker get
you a fuckum sticker but fuckum is so
important right it's such a good it's
such a good protest phrase right because
it's not aimed at one certain ideology
it can be aimed at any ideology if you
really want to know the truth or any
idea or any stupid
statement someone telling you what to do
or what not to do you can say [__] them
[__] them [__] them [__] them and I
think that's the reason why this whole
thing caught on Tammy says I want a
sticker all right Tammy here let me show
you how to let me show you how to get
the sticker you just go to the Tony
michaels.com you pan on down hit my my
dog hates Ted merch the sticker is in
that store the my dog hates Ted merch we
should do more um than just Ted Cruz
maybe what we'll do next next week is we
will decide as a
collective if we're going to put my dog
hates Greg Abbott my dog hates Donald
Trump my dog hates Marjorie Taylor green
who shall it be on the next merch and we
should create some new merch is what we
should do but if you want to just go to
store.the Tony michaels.com or go to the
Tony michaels.com pan on down and hit
the my dog hates day cruise merch if you
want one of these fancy fancy Dancy [__]
them stickers and get several of them
and stick them on your Maga family's
bathroom mirrors or
something but it's very important it's
very important the [__] the [__]
protest and the [__] phrase um it's
an
attitude it's kind of a personality
trait if you want to know the honest
truth it's what that's I mean you know
it's what I like about it because it's
the best [__] is the best protest work
[__] you [__] them [__] him [__] her
[__] him you know what I mean
so um I think we should make sure that
we are getting people to join our
Coalition in operation go commando
operation go Commander our first Target
in this
operation is the is the Carville
Commandos that's where the the name
operation go commando came from and the
rat [__] Patrol um at over there at
carville's hangout we're going to ban
with them we're going to ban with other
uh groups and other
coalitions throughout this but I think I
think the reason why carville's
Coalition the Carville Commandos is so
important first is because of The
Branding we really want The Branding to
be correct because that way when other
PE when people start paying attention
that hey there's a public alliance
between these influencers
groups and they're going to save
democracy no matter what the [__] no
matter what the [__] they have to say or
how they have to say it or who they have
to
mock I think it's a great idea I think
it's a great
idea to get a coalition together that
isn't the establishment so they can't
tell us what we can and cannot say oh
yeah oh you don't want to say that we
don't give a [__] [__] them we're going
to say what we need to say to save our
democracy we don't give a [__] if it
offend you f [__] her [__] them you know
what I mean [__] them [__] them [__]
them [__]
them
so just go to operation go commando
operation go to Commando I think we're
gonna we made a hashtag this morning on
Twitter maybe we should hashtag on
Facebook hash operation go
commando um so if if you're on Twitter
make sure to get on Twitter if you're if
you have a Twitter account I'm telling
you I know I know it feels like I don't
want to go over there there's a bunch of
Nazis over there well let me tell you
something the best place to go to punch
a Nazi it's where all the Nazis are
hanging out that's the best place and
let me tell you something too about Elon
Musk this is kind of collateral damage
that he's caused over there um on
um on on Twitter or exchan as he calls
it now is um is that you can post
anything you want over there now like
you can just [__] say anything and
post anything you want anything I don't
give a [__] what it is here let me show
you let me show you a good example of
this um this morning I I posted and this
may be real this may be AI I don't know
I mean it's possible right I think I
posted this didn't I post this I thought
we posted this H maybe we
didn't a damn it I posted a few things
this morning we're working on so many
videos oh here we go here we go this is
the one this is the one I wanted oh [__]
hang on [__] technical difficulties
what a what a bonehead I am I keep not
clicking the correct button before the
next button you know what I mean I get
too excited here's Donald Trump talking
about James Carville and he says
something about me too let's let's watch
I'm hearing some magga rumors people are
saying people are saying this loser
James Carville has these crazy Carville
Commandos they're supposed to hook up
with the [__] him fam and Tony Michaels
the rush of the left total losers
probably fake news but I hope they don't
go too hard on the sift
card I hope they don't do go too hard on
the sift card I think Donald Trump is
scared that um that James Carville and
the Carville Commandos will join the
[__] fam and the Tony Michaels the
rustling ball the left to really lean
into the whole he's got syphilis thing
and he's got
clap everyone's excited about this
everyone's excited about this that Trump
Trump's saying my name and Trump's
saying Caro listen I'm hearing some
magga rumors people are saying people
are saying this loser James Carville has
these crazy Carville Commandos they're
supposed to hook up with the [__] him
fam and Tony Michaels the rush of the
left total losers probably fake news but
I hope they don't go too hard on the
sift card uh Pam says Tony you shouldn't
show that fake stuff no we absolutely
should I'm gonna disagree with you Pam I
appreciate the Descent I appreciate the
direction but we are absolutely going to
use AI to the fullest extent and there
is nothing I may not make the AI
machines say and do to save our
democracy trust me they are going to use
this weapon AI against us and against
democracy trust me on this these
fascists will use any weapon they can to
destroy democracy we must make sure that
we harness the power of AI to save it it
is super important super important again
there's nothing there's nothing that I
may not say or do not to save to save
democracy and if that takes mocking
Donald Trump
if that takes mocking Donald Trump then
fine whatever or if I have to show you
clip after clip of people saying this
kind of [__] well I voted for Nikki
Haley because I was Voting against
Donald Trump and what what propelled you
to get to this point I want to I'm 74
years old I've lived in a constitutional
democracy all my life I want to remain
that way and I want my grandchildren to
grow up in one there you go folks FKS
it's working it's working it's [__]
working it's working our messaging is
working even people out there voting
aren't [__] listening to the
mainstream media soft gloving this stuff
and framing it up and and taking Donald
Trump as normal and normalizing his
Fascism and normalizing his I'm gonna be
a dick taster look I want to taste dick
just for one day only one day I love the
taste of dick but only for a day that's
how it
works they're not buying it and it's
good that we keep yelling and screaming
it and that it's the
threat not a dictatorship and I'm
curious over the last two elections um
have you voted Trump in the past was it
something where you voted for him you
trusted him and you were disappointed
yes I voted for him in 2016 I am a
registered Republican and I I regretted
that vote almost IM
immediately Tony Trump can
win okay all right
yeah Trump can't win folks can't win he
won in 2016 because no one knew this
[__] right just what this [__] lady
said just what she said I voted for him
in
2016 and I regretted it
immediately immediately do you know how
many [__] people in this country
regret their vote for him in 2016 and
then regret voting for him twice in 2020
after he tried to overturn the overturn
our Constitution and [__] on it and rip
it
up and make and and invalidate our
[__] votes in our
elections by trying to commit a coup to
overturn the government [__] that [__]
I'm telling you there's a hell of a lot
of people who voted for Trump twice who
were G to go vote for Biden that's right
even in red states there are going to be
people who voted twice for Trump against
Biden in 2020 that are going to go vote
for him not because they like Biden not
because they want Biden to be the
president it's because Donald Trump is a
treasonous piece of trash and they don't
want that treasonous piece of trash
anywhere near our [__]
government it's our government not his
not theirs it's [__] ours
it's the people's government and we give
them the authority through
elections especially on his trip to
Europe where he insulted our allies and
praised
Putin and then in 2020 was that enough
for you to change your vote to Joe Biden
yes absolutely why did you feel the need
to to cross party lines because I want
the world to be a safe place I believe
in a strong NATO my father fought in
World War II to defeat fascism
I want it to remain defeated godamn
she's antifa [__] yeah she's invited
wait wait wait wait is this is this
Grand TAA I don't know I I mean I'm just
saying look look look here look here all
right look
here look here I'm just saying I'm just
saying I'm saying man I'm just saying
man just saying I think we found Gran
Tia right I think we found
her oh [__] there's gonna be so many
goddamn Gras it's not even gonna be
funny so thank you Granda there in New
Hampshire coming to your [__] senses
now you say oh well Tony this is just
this is just one person this is just one
person that is saying this type of
stuff surely surely Grand TAA is the
only
one is the only one that would be saying
this type of [__] well
maybe let's see what these Grand tias
say anything but Trump that was your
priority that's my PRI is that the
biggest reason you supported Nicki hilly
yeah I'd say because of Donald Trump yes
yeah and I have no problem with the
ladies running things hey have one
here he's like look I got Grand div with
me
oh folks this idea that young folks
support Trump is dumber than dog [__]
and this idea that that that older
folks are gonna support Donald Trump
because because Biden's old is dumber
than [__] dog [__] it's dumber than
the idea that Donald Trump has big
support with with [__] young people
what the [__] are you talking about the
hell are you trying what the are you
[__] me come on
man that ain't a thing it's not even
close to being a thing but you know you
can't tell the delusional speaking of
delusional in last night's election um a
lot of people saying that Marjorie
Taylor green the petty Yeti was [__]
wasted she was
drunk which I mean I'm assuming she's
always drunk if if you know the truth
you don't say some of the [__] you say
without being inebriated I mean maybe
she's just that [__] dumb it's
possible and maybe I'm not giving you
know dumb enough credit
here stupidity enough
[__] credit for the [__] she
says but a lot of people thought she was
wasted I don't know I'm gonna let you
find out here but last night last night
Nikki Haley almost beat Trump now it was
double digits and it's a far cry from
from uh um a close race but he's the
incumbent okay he's the incumbent and
he's the cult leader and he is the
presumptive nominee who they bow to who
they [__] worship they think God sent
him here okay they're gonna drink the
[__]
Kool-Aid there's going to be a Kool-Aid
moment
100% no way there isn't a Kool-Aid
but double
digits is a far cry from a resounding
victory for the incumbent I mean if you
want if you want to know about an
incumbent Victory which I'll show you
the incumbent Victory on the other side
of Joe Biden in a rightand campaign
stomping the [__] out of Maryann
Williamson whoever the [__] that is and
this Dean Phillips [__] he might as
well change his party affiliation to
Republican he's going to need it to be a
politician from here on
out but margorie Taylor green last night
just can't stop [__] puking up
[__] and again I don't know if it's
the Vodka what do you think she drinks
at White
House I think I think she definitely
drinks vodka right and the reason why is
because it's
Russian I like a white russian I like
man I I actually Ain to White Russians I
love white Russians I'll order them at
bars they're usually expensive bars um I
make sure if they're going to make me a
White Russian though they're not using
the [__] well vodka I'm like come on
man you're going to charge me eight
bucks for a [__] drink don't be using
no goddamn well
vodka um but I would imagine that she
likes vodka because it's Russian just
because of that right and she may be
drinking white Russians because it's got
the name Russian in it I mean she loves
[__] Putin she loves giving fellatio
to Putin um let's let's let's see her
talk to her boyfriend here I'm not
[__] you this guy with holding the
microphone is her boyfriend they [__]
each other can you imagine [__] him
or her can you imagine them two
[__] let me play the clip
while try to keep myself from getting
sick these are fake numbers Nikki Haley
does not have this much support she's
going to come out and claim that she's
right rising in the polls all these fake
news media people up here on this
platform are going to claim that Nikki
Haley is rising in the polls it's a
total complete lie AB n
Hy look the polls say and the Nikki the
Nikki ha the Nikki Haley says she she
hang on hang
on she she lie lie he a lie she's
[__] wasted right I think they're
right she's totally [__] wasted
absolute lie tonight Nikki Haley was
defeated the problem is she's going to
be dumb enough and she's gonna be a fake
candidate wait wait wait wait wait wait
wait wait wait wait wait wait wait wait
wait stop did she just say did she just
say Nikki Haley is dumb
enough
Marjorie Taylor
green margorie Taylor green
said that Nikki Haley is dumb
enough you can't make this [__]
up oh you can't make this [__]
up oh keep going you stupid [__] and
she's gonna keep going and we're going
to destroy her and South Carolina it's
going to be a a complete humiliation I
can't wait to see it happen so I'm it's
going to be a
complete complete
humiliation she said that Nicki Haley
this this [__] [__] said Nikki Haley
is dumb
enough Marjorie Taylor green calling
some other [__]
dumb okay all right I guess she's an
expert on dumb I mean there's that right
there's that she's an expert on being
dumb baby oh
man son of a
[__] woe woo wooa speaking of Dum and
the other side of the ticket because I
want to talk about that for a second I
don't want to I don't want to leave out
Dean
Philips Dean Phillips he thought he won
last night I'm not [__] you he
thought he won he had a Howard Dean
moment not to be confused with Dean Dean
Phillips but here's how he reacted to
Biden stomping his ass in a right in a
Right End campaign spread the word put
something on social media call your
friends call your family say you know
what this unknown congressman from
Minnesota came here 10 weeks ago and
just got
21% of the
vote yeah oh he came here and yeah he
got Republicans to vote for him using
Haron Hitler's money yay even though
Biden didn't go to New Hampshire once
Biden didn't spend a single [__] dime
in New Hampshire and the reason why is
because he got into a squabble with the
Democratic party and they wouldn't put
him on the ballot so he's like okay [__]
you I'll do a writing campaign and Dean
Phillips got got 21% of the
vote folks this this this is only proof
only and I'm telling you I'm telling you
Dean Phillips's campaign with his
supporters in New Hampshire with the
money he spent are
MAA they're [__] they're [__] it's
all a [__] ruse right it's all a
[__]
ruse I I know I know you're like whoa
whoa whoa whoa whoa Tony whoa there's
some Democrats that voted for Dean yeah
I understand that there's some [__]
Democrats that are idiot out there I'm
not going to deny it there's some libes
out there that lost their [__] minds
that aren't that are full of [__] that
don't know [__] from Shinola they got
their [__] head so far up their ass
they can't see the light of day I
understand it I get
it but you believe you believe the 21
that the 21% that Dean Phillips got and
partial part of it wasn't organization
from the right to register as
Independence that are registered as
Independence to go vote for him to try
to somehow convince people that Joe
Biden isn't a good
candidate come on man this is what the
right-wing does this is what they've
always done is try to [__] manipulate
things to make you think things that
aren't real Dean Phillips does not have
support in New Hampshire nor anywhere
else in the country to be the Democratic
nominee and the reason why is because
Joe Biden is the incumbent president of
the democratic party that's how it works
Dean Phillips will not attract a single
not a single superdelegate not
one and Dolls Joe Biden needs is all the
super delegates and he'll be the [__]
nominee that's the
point and anyone who doesn't understand
that who tells you about Maryann
Williamson or Dean Phillips or any of
this [__] doesn't know what the [__]
they're talking about okay they don't
know what the [__] they're talking about
either that or their [__] lying to
you it's the same stupid [__] of people
telling you that Nikki Haley was going
to win New Hampshire there was no
[__] way let me say it there is no
[__] way Nikki Haley was gonna win
New Hampshire no
way and I would like to add to
this that Joe Biden in his writing
campaign beating this stupid
[__] whipping his ass in a rting
campaign where he didn't spend a single
dollar not a [__] dime didn't go to
New Hampshire once not once did he go to
New
Hampshire all Joe Biden does is get up
in the morning put his [__] shoes on
and does his [__]
job that's
it and Dean Phillips here used
Republican money to rec rep recruit
Republicans who are registered as
Independence to come vote for him to
make someone believe somewhere some dumb
[__] that Joe Biden isn't
popular get the [__] out of here with
that [__] let's go to his Dean Phillips
moment here yeah I love you all let's do
it
everybody I don't know if you remember
Howard
Dean now it's going to be a Dean
Phillips
moment remember that when he won
Iowa's and the next day they're like
whoa this guy's [__] off his rocker
this guy's lost his mind that was like
normal politics you remember that that
was like normal bille in
politics oh [__] those days are long
gone aren't they long gone those days
maybe we can get back there in the next
20 years I doubt it but we'll
see we'll see poor Dean Phillips poor
Dean and you know what really I know a
lot of people want Dean Phils to drop
out including my my good friend
Christopher web um he wants Dean to drop
out but here's the thing I actually I
think Dean's spending Republican
money so all right I mean after the
showing last night in a rting campaign
imagine what Joe Biden's gonna do when
Joe Biden's actually on the [__]
ballot when he's actually on the [__]
ballot
hm I wonder what the hell is going to
happen I don't
know we'll
see so last night after Donald Trump
wins the New Hampshire primary barely he
barely
wins he should have won like Joe Biden
won I mean [__] Joe Biden got more votes
in New Hampshire on a writing campaign
that Donald Trump got think about
that think about that but at his at at
this speech um let me show you his
speech first here with Tim Scott this
[__] bootlicker do you guys remember
Tim Scott from the um from the uh from
South Carolina now he's already endorsed
Donald Trump he's a US senator he's an
Uncle Tom I'm gonna say it I don't give
a [__] I'll say it okay fine I'm racist
it's this guy right here in the back
right and then you got this other guy
here in the back rad damama dingdong
and then Grandpa Hitler is out here act
like he likes black people and acts like
he likes people like radama dingdong
right he like look I got me a black
friend and I got me one of them other
type I don't know where he's from I got
them one other type
friends REM ding dong and Uncle Tom I
mean Uncle Scott that's what I
meant Uncle Uncle Tom
Scott um and then this [__] the
dumbest son ever is Eric back here Eric
look like he's just been introduced to
running water back here what's water
what's what's water oh and it runs what
do you mean it runs does it have
legs does it run like it has legs no no
it comes out of a faucet dummy oh is
that what that is it comes out of a
faucet oh okay this water
oh but watch the boot licking that
happens here first off he re he
misgenders Tim Scott I think I think he
misgenders Tim Scott which I don't give
a [__] I would misgender Tim Scott hell
I would miss race Tim Scott I'm like
whoa dude you're a white Christian
nationalist oh that's the whitest
[__] thing I've ever seen but he
misgenders Tim Scott Uncle Tom Scott
here excuse me Uncle Tom
Scott um if you don't like what I'm
saying about it I don't give a [__]
listen I've done told you I done told
you I'm going to say [__] that you're
not L that's going to offend a lot of
people from here until November and
probably past November if you want to be
quite honest about it once I get on a
roll I don't stop you guys know that but
I don't give a [__] anymore I don't give
a [__] and I I know a lot of people in
this audience don't give a [__] and
aren't offended by anything they just
want democracy to survive and they're
willing to say whatever the [__] they
need to say to make it survive just like
me but anyways Uncle Tom Scott here
Trump misgenders him in this clip but
watch what he does at the end and let me
tell you something I I know this seems
irrelevant but this is what they're all
going to do they're all going to
bootlick this [__] and the
reason why they're going to bootlick
this [__] is because they're
sitting they have Sitting Senate seats
and in in Republican party they're
sitting House Seats they want to be
elected folks this is the best thing
that ever can happen and I'm going to
show you the beauty of it right here I'm
going to show you the beauty of it right
here because they're going to they're
going to totally [__]
devalue and discount and debase
themselves to make this guy think they
love him watch did you ever think that
she actually appointed you
Tim and think of it appointed and you're
the senator of his State and she
endorsed me how St you must really hate
her no it's it's a shame it's a shame
watch watch what he says he comes up to
even say it to lick them boots listen
listen to this Uncle Tom lick these
[__] this [__] racist boots uh
oh I just love you no that's that's why
he's a great
[Applause]
politician I [__] love it I [__]
love it I love it every single last one
I'm gonna do it look at look at radam
ding Dong's face back there look at his
face ah I did the same I had to do the
same thing H I had to lick his boots
just like you lick at his
boots I had to I had to act like a
[__]
jackass
hum look at this
[__] eat your [__] hearts
out I'm telling you this is the best
[__] thing that could ever happen cuz
all these [__] going to fall in
line Marco Rubio's already endorsed him
they're all going to fall well they're
all going to fall Ronda Santa say
endorsed him the minute the minute that
Nikki Haley drops out of this race she
is gonna have to endorse him she's gonna
have to endorse this [__] the
minute she drops out of the race the
same almost the same sentence I suck and
it sucks to suck and let's see oh yeah
the Republican party is a bunch of white
Christian nationalist okay and I I can't
I can't [__] win because I'm a woman
in this party and they [__] hate
women so I can't I can't win um so I'm
just going to drop out and then I'm
going to endorse silly woman I'm going
to endorse I'm going to
endorse Trump even after she said this
last night even after she said this
she's going to endorse him
watch with Donald Trump Republicans have
lost almost every competitive election
we lost the Senate we lost the house we
lost the White House we lost in 2018 we
lost in 2020 and we lost in
2022 the worst kept secret in politics
is how badly the Democrats want to run
against Donald
Trump goddamn right we do they know
Trump is the only Republican in the
country who Joe Biden can
defeat n know I want why I want Nikki to
stay in oh my God not only do I want her
to spend all that [__] that
Republican donor money oh man I mean
hundreds of millions of dollars of that
[__] [__] yeah half billion [__] let's
get it up to two billion dollar let's
spend let's spend $2 billion let's
funnel $2 billion do into the economy
Republican donor money to [__] with
Trump to keep Nikki Haley in it [__] him
you goddamn right and the other reason
why is because when she does [__]
Kiss the Ring when she
goes when she finally does [__] lick
his boots and we get to show these clips
over and over and over and over again
and she has to be on the campaign Trail
asking the question why did you if
you're supporting him why did you say
this the same way with governor sonunu
that's what I want that's what I want
because the country is going to hear
that
[__] because we're gonna yell and scream
that [__]
[__] keep
going you can't fix you can't fix the
mess if you don't win an election win a
trump nomination is a Biden win and a
KLA Harris president
presidency oh what's so [__] wrong
with that you goddamn right keep going
[__] hails to the Y Nicki hay.com
Keeper in the [__] race keep her in
the [__] race make this a two sludge
two fascist sludge race you goddamn
right what the
[__] CH I mean listen most people in
this country most people in this country
country would vote for [__] Joe
Biden's corpse before they'd vote for
Donald Trump so yeah whatever about the
[__] KLA Harris thing good good on
you because I'm telling you I'm telling
you right now they would [__] vote
for Joe Biden's
corpse his
corpse before they'd vote for that piece
of
[__] I mean oh you don't believe me here
they played it on Fox News here's
another one here's another guy
who does this guy looks like he votes
for he definitely looks like he votes
for Donald Trump didn't he he looks like
he's part of me Team Six looks like he
goes to the Golden Corral after their
after their [__] cosplay operations
they got going on watch Donald Trump
really disgraced
himself Donald Trump really disgraced
himself keep going Nikki keep going
Nikki
oh keep going Nikki I can't I hope she
keeps going of course Trump's trying to
get her to drop out because he's
terrified of this he really is terrified
of this that Nikki ay's gonna see keep
saying this [__] and saying this [__]
and saying this [__] the more the more
it happens the longer it'll go on right
and the more people will start to doubt
that he'll be the nominee more people
start to doubt that he that he's not
going to win right oh maybe these
criminal trials maybe he'll get
convicted maybe he'll get tossed off
these B he won't he won't he
won't and that's what the donors are
thinking that they're going to keep
funneling their money to Nikki Haley
maybe we'll see I think after South
Carolina she she ain't got not only it
doesn't matter about the money anymore
after South Carolina she gets trounced
by 70 [__] points in South Carolina
there's a 70 point margin between her
and Trump and her home state where she
was the
governor that's it's
done it's [__] done but listen what
Trump has in store for her let's see if
we can figure out what he's talking
about here good luck and just a little
note to Nikki yeah she's not gonna win a
little note to Nikki a little note to
Nikki she's not gonna win I think he's
been listening to my show maybe I
actually think there are Trump uh Trump
someone in the Trump campaign comes and
watch this show somewhere there's white
Christian nationalists that come watch
this show because they know that we
[__] harp on them and we [__]
pound on that drum a lot every single
[__] day and the reason why is
because they're the [__] disease this
guy is just a symptom of their
disease but he's like he in this clip
he's like hey Nikki Nikki let me tell
you something those are nice kneecaps I
really like your kneecaps they're sex o
the sexiest o the sexiest kneecaps it
would be a shame if something happened
to those sexy kneecaps
Haley but if she did she would be under
invest instigation by those people in 15
minutes and I could tell you five
reasons why already look at look at V
back there look how terrified he is look
at him he's like oh my God oh my God he
said the same thing to me he told me
that on the phone that I got sexy
kneecaps and and if I like my kneecaps
and I better I better start licking the
boots look at him he's terrified back
there look at this guy Tim's got the
same way these stup f two [__] Uncle
Tom bootlickers are they're scared man
they're
scared listen listen I've got the dirt
on you it's all lies it's every single
bit of it is lies I don't care we're
gonna say the lies and we're gonna make
sure that people threaten you threaten
your families make you move out of your
homes because that's what MAA does we're
domestic terrorists remember we're
domestic
terrorists that's what they do keep
going Grandpa Hitler hostages
not big reasons a little stuff that she
doesn't want to talk about she be under
investigation within minutes and so
would Ron have
been he's still throwing out thre
threats to Ron he's like look Ron don't
change your endorsement don't change
don't change don't change
man oh this guy is terrified decided to
get out he decided to get out he decided
to get out I called and I threatened him
I threatened him I said look I've got
the beef on I will I will get people to
say I will get people to say that you
that you're a pedophile that's what I
will do he called Ronda santis a
pedophile did you know that he called
Ronda sanz's pedophile on fraud social
on his social media account over there
he called Ronda Santa a [__]
pedophile and Ron's like yeah I want to
endorse that guy I mean Ted Cruz did it
why can't I do
it okay all right but he threatens Nikki
Haley here look you better you better
not you better get out you better get
out of the race better get out of the
race or I'm GNA talk about your Affairs
that's what he's actually talking about
um some people have surmised that Nikki
Haley has had an affair an affairs with
with an S and affairs with an S which I
mean that's possible um she's definitely
a republican so
I wouldn't put uh her outside you know
not having family
values oh boy but uh apparently that's
that's what that's what the rightwing
has been circulating for months and
months and months um I actually hope for
Nikki Haley's sake that she gets out too
uh you know I I joke and I want her to
spend a lot of
[__] I want to um people are saying
people are saying people are saying on
Discord people say that Nikki Haley has
[__] Pete Davidson um I'm just you
know putting that out there that um some
people are saying that Nikki Haley has
[__] Pete Davidson which I mean I
actually think that's a plus that's a
positive I don't know that that's such a
knock I don't know if that's going to
work um but you
know back to the Tim Scott and the um
the boot looking thing I want to um I
want to ask you guys a question this is
like a like a live bowl here in the chat
are you ready for this okay so who did
it better who did it better was it
Samuel
Jackson and Jango and chained or was it
Tim Scott and Grandpa Hitler Unchained
which one did it better was it Samuel
Jackson or Tim Scott Samuel Jackson or
Tim Scott who did it better Samuel
Jackson or Tim
Scott oh [__] him what an Uncle Tom he
is an Uncle Tom I don't know what to
tell you lot of people don't like that
phrase it's an easy way of saying you
know saying what you want to say uh
speaking of candidates and saying what
you want to say I'm trying to figure out
okay do I want to talk more about how
the right-wing [__] is racist is
[__] or do we want to go down um Alina
Haba DSL Lane what do we want to talk
about do we want to talk about alen H's
second lips or do we want to talk about
how the right-wing hates black people
like we've got a choice here you know we
can go we can go two different ways here
we go one way or the other I don't know
which way you guys want to go um but you
know what let's do both [__] it let's do
both um so this Trumper posted a a
picture of someone on their account and
she says Miss s says and here you can
see her her profile here it says um
former investment banker columia Mama of
7 conservative Centrist reaction what ex
Democrat what the [__] does any of this
mean none of that none of that sounds
anything you're [__] idiot
fjb [__] Joe Biden is what she says now
misss says this is Trump's lawyer Eat
Your Heart Out Biden all right now
here's this is a photo of Alina habba
I'm assuming this is marago it kind of
looks like a [__] hole so I'm guessing
this is a a pull at Mar Lago and I'm not
going to lie I'm not going to lie atena
have a with them dsls that she's got it
really I mean she looks like she can
suck a mean dick doesn't she I'm just
saying I'm just saying maybe not her
whole life but since she's been with
grantpa Hitler she definitely
is worked it out I'm just
saying but I think she's got dsls here
and I'm pretty good set of them I'm just
saying I bet I bet Alina Hamber could
suck a mean one now the problem is is I
don't know why Joe Biden would be um
Envy of this right she says eat your
heart out Biden so I guess I guess she
wants Biden to jack off to Alina Hava
picture which I mean there's way better
porn than this there's way better porn
than this right I mean she doesn't look
bad in the swim suit I'm not saying
she's ugly frankly she looks pretty hot
to me right I think that's why Trump
hired her not because she's smart not
because she's a good lawyer for sure I
don't know if you've heard her speak or
heard some of her legal analysis but
she's a [__] bonehead so it wasn't
because she's got good a good legal
brain I would say it's because she's got
a good set of Honkers and and a good set
of dsls is the reason why Donald Trump
hired her um but I mean that would be
what my guess but I I said she looks
like she sucks a mean dick but Biden is
married and not indicted with 91 bellies
so why would he give a [__] if this is
Trump's lawyer like why would he give a
[__] he ain't he ain't gonna go to
prison he ain't gonna go to Criminal
Court I what does he give a [__] and nor
does he need nor does he need a pair of
dsls right this is an 81 year old man
who's happily married he doesn't need a
[__] set of dsls
around I don't understand what she's
trying to say I'm just you
know what a [__] bonee head eat your
heart
out I mean again we live in a world
where you can look up any kind of porn
any kind of porn like it doesn't matter
the
Kink get your hands on just about
anything
nowadays why in the [__] would you would
you would you [__] beat your meat to
a picture
of Alina Haba I mean what in the [__] is
so attractive about this right what is
so attractive about this oh this is Oh I
thought this was Alina habit and her
Goof Troop sorry I thought that was oops
maybe this is a is this real or is this
AI I don't know looks real to me looks
real to me looks real to me looks like
Lena H having lunch you know what I
mean
[Applause]
oh what are you gonna do I want to goof
a little bit that's how we do here um
apparently that was Donald Trump's new
legal team apparently all right let's go
back to Republicans hate black people I
want to get to that too yeah I got a
black friend his name's Tim Scott and
he's a boot
licker there's my africanamerican back
here there's my
American
indien oh what whatever ramama Dam
dingdong whatever he is whatever he is
he's my
friend let's see how Charlie Kirk feels
about feel about black people flying
planes this is [__] real I didn't
make this up either this is [__] real
let's see
him let's see how Charlie Kirk feels
about black black pilots and that's why
I think this United story in the Dei
story hits so hard because we've all
been in the back of a plane when the
turbulence hits or when you're flying
through a storm and you're like I'm so
glad I saw the guy with the right stuff
and the square jaw get into the cockpit
before we the guy with the right stuff
and the square
jaw they a hiding anymore okay fine
I'm hiding anymore man they're a behind
him listen to this wh watch what Charlie
says after this guy pukes up his racist
misogynous sludge we took off and I Noah
says yeah this this dude this dude is
gay as [__] he totally is is this guy
this guy's a clauset all these guys are
Claus of of gay men I mean that's what
we have to assume someone who doubt
protests that
much about trans and gay people they
love to watch [__] [__] in their porn
they love it and they love they love
women with a [__] on them I mean I'm
just assuming I don't know I feel better
now think like you want to go thought
crime like I'm sorry if I see a black
pilot I'm gonna be like boy I hope he's
qualified
[Laughter]
listen I love when they just they just
say it out there they you know a lot of
people get offended by this like oh my
god did you hear what Charlie Kirk said
did you hear what he said he said this
well yeah no [__] he's a [__] racist
he's a goddamn Nazi he's a [__]
racist Nazi are you and you're surprised
and you're offended that he [__] says
this [__] what the [__] of course
Charlie Kirk that racist [__] Nazi is
gonna say this [__] of course he is of
course he is going to say this [__] stop
being
surprised
stop the problem is there not enough
people are hearing that Charlie Kirk who
by the way I don't know if you know this
Charlie Kirk Charlie Kirk here he raised
money and spent money to bust Trump
supporters to January
6 he used turning points USA money to
put people on [__] buses and bust
them to the [__] treasonous in
Insurrection that Donald Trump and him
planned they planned it they planned an
Insurrection they planned to overthrow
our government Charlie Kirk here right
enough of America does not know that
fact they don't know that fact [__] most
of America don't even know who this
[__] bonehead is and every one of
them should know who Charlie Kirk is
every single [__] American should
know who this racist [__] misogynist
Nazi is they should all know who he is
and I hope Charlie keeps talking and
talking and talking until every single
American knows who the [__] he
is look at him he's so [__] pissed
off here that Taylor Swift is more
popular than him look at him he's like
what what what kind of racist [__] do I
gotta say to be more popular than Taylor
Swift okay what kind of racist [__] do I
have to
say to get more people to R register to
vote I just want I just want people to
register to vote and vote for Nazis so
that we don't have elections
anymore I just don't want women to vote
anymore that way that way more people
like me can get an office because we
can't get an office by being voted in we
have to use authoritarianism to to rule
over people and Taylor Swift stands in
my way by the way
why is his face so [__] small you
notice that you ever noticed that this
guy's got the head of a beach ball but
his face is the size of a
dime how does that happen is this a
birth
effect I'm just asking is this a birth
effect is this an actual thing where you
got a big [__] melon but a small
[__] face right I don't know I mean
my I'm beautiful I have to say I'm
[__] sexy you know what I mean and
yes someone asked earlier I'm going to
point this out someone asked Philip
asked earlier did I get a haircut again
you goddamn right I got a haircut look
at that [__] look at that [__] I don't
[__] around when I get a haircut you
know what I
mean thank you Phillip says I look good
I know I know I look good I know I look
good my proportions are right I look
damn good I'm a nice looking guy right I
can grow a [__] beard right a proper
[__] beard not that [__] [__]
that some of these [__] fake ass fake
ass country boys like Nikki like Nikki
soy boy that Jess was talking about ear
or Charlie Kirk or any of these other
[__] idiots on this podcast they
shave their face how manly is that huh
oh you shave it
clean what are you getting ready for a
pat smear on your face huh is that why
you shaved her
clean the [__] out of here and punk ass
[__] Charlie Kirky is really mad
that Taylor Swift can get more people to
vote and he's willing to say racist [__]
he's willing to say racist [__] to prove
his point watch yeah sorry if I see a
black pilot I'm gonna be like boy I hope
he's qualified well that's the wouldn't
have done that you wouldn't have you
wouldn't have done that before that's
not an immediate you would who I am
that's not what I believe it is the
reality that's not wait wait wait it's
not who I am that's not what I believe I
it's not that's not who I am that's not
what I believe I'm just saying out loud
that I believe it that I I believe it
Speaking of beards look at these guys
look at this guy he needs to have gender
reconfirming uh care here holy [__]
[__] look at this guy look at the Dome
on this dude this guy took way too much
test way too much gear in the gym and
he's got nothing to show for it
right this guy again his [__] head is
the size of a beach ball and his face is
the size of a dime and this guy over
here he's stoned to the bone look at him
he's got to be stoned to listen to these
three [__] idiots and he can't even
grow a proper beard you know this guy
this is a pizza gate Guy this is the guy
who focuses so much on on children being
molested and children being trafficked
that he [__] he [__] he he spread
the lie that there's a basement in a
pizza place in DC and a shooter went in
there to shoot him up because he didn't
have the [__] common sense to figure
out if there was a goddamn basement in
that place anyways
Jesus Christ this is the best they got
folks this is the best they
got okay these racist [__] fous
little slugs here are the best they
got we're gonna beat the [__] pants
off these [__] in
November why do you think they keep
[__] losing why do you think Trump
keeps Los why do you think maanga keeps
losing why because they listen to [__]
like
this they listen to [__] like these
look at this I've never seen so many
[__] with two pays
on and then one that's you know bald as
[__] Jesus [__]
Christ if the black person's flying the
plane I got a I got a I got a question
it you know what I mean you know what I
mean you know what I mean I got to
question it oh here's a here's a better
picture of Charlie here's a more
accurate picture of Charlie here a
closeup a closeup here of Charlie Kirk's
face [__] you
Charles [__] you
Charles oh
[__] you know he lives in Arizona right
Charlie Kirk Charlie Kirk lives in
Arizona he lives in Arizona and I wish I
could show you this clip I wish we had
have time to talk about this but we only
got a few minutes left but I want to
point this out Don Lewis had this um on
his Twitter account it is two recordings
oh wait that's Charlie here it is it's
two recordings here and it's it's it's a
recording of the the Arizona Republican
party chair Jeff DT oh he's a dwit all
right he's a tweet the Tweet um he's
trying to bribe Carri leak not to run
for Senate it's a real [__] thing and
it's the it got the recordings
apparently Carrie Lake recorded this
conversation and sold it to the Daily
Mail you know she's got to make some
some money somehow I mean she can't make
money down at Marl Lago anymore because
Donald Trump has already made sure to
endorse her in the US Senate race so now
she's got to do that she can't be VP
there isn't going to be a vice president
president there's not going to be a vice
presidential pick on the Trump
ticket stop talking about it it's a
waste of time stefanic is not gonna be
the vi BP not Carrie Lake not margorie
Taylor green not Lauren bobbert not
Nikki Haley there there's not going to
be one uh but I do what I do want to
show you is um one uh video uh before we
go the white Christian nationalist Laura
witz um I don't know if you guys know
this but she was actually the GOP and
right-wing watch points it out here she
was actually the GOP candidate for
Senate in 2020 she was their gal in 2020
this was their Senate candidate in
Delaware now listen to what she says
here about 911 I believe that um 911 was
a human sacrifice on a mass scale I
think that you know they have been doing
this work with these demons and but the
devil Demands a Sacrifice look at any
Hol person inol would or famous person
they had to sacrifice something whether
it was their innocence or another person
or a thing or a child in order to get
where they are what they had to what
they had to what they had to sacrifice a
child one of their children what the
[__] are you talking about what did you
have to do to get where you're at [__]
that's what I want to know what's this
projection you got going on here holy
[__] okay well keep going you have to
Pro like provide a sacrifice and if the
government is working with with these
demons they demand their sacrifice and
just killing one person isn't going to
be enough you have to 3,000 oh live
television oh in every classroom a
public room public school classroom in
the country so it was very much so I
believe that 911 like spiritually was a
human sacrifice uh some kind of
sacrificial um presentation for the
powers that be that are taking over our
government and working with our
government huh you know what this is
this is projection this is actually
called foreshadowing all right so what
Laura wins is doing here is Laura wisk
is actually foreshadowing what they want
to do I hope he go full dictator
scorcher and that's what that's what she
wants is she wants him to go full
dictator scorched Earth and kill
catapulting illegals over the wall
thousand be awesome thousands of people
she's foreshadowing they did it to us we
will do it to them is what she's saying
I guess the government did it to us so
we're going to do it to them we want to
kill these people that's what she's
doing she's foreshadowing white
Christian nationalism is the threat it's
always been the threat Trump is not the
threat Trump is the [__] symptom of
the disease of white Christian
nationalism get it straight get the
messaging on make sure make sure that
you're participating in operation go
commando go hashtag that [__] on Twitter
go hashtag that [__] on Facebook tag
James Carville tag me tell
tell raing we have to get these
coalitions together we got to get them
together we got to mock together we got
to message together and we have to pound
the sand of democracy win yeah for the
win for the win win win when we gota win
by much more than what Dean Phillips
lost by oh boy oh boy the Tony Michaels
podcast as you know every single weekday
Monday through Friday noon Eastern 11
please go to the Tony michaels.com click
the Subscribe button at the top join
team tattoo that's team tattoo you'll
get to see the live stream in my tattoo
on Friday two more days two more days
put any amount in the team tattoo fund
$1 $5 $10 $15 whatever amount you want
to put in the teen tattoo fund we are so
close to our goal so very close I mean
it would take like five people to give
$25 10 people to give
$15 15 people to give
$10 five people to give 20 or 20 to give
$5 and we'd hit our goal also go join
the uh patreon page for free and join
the Discord server and the book club
don't forget to relink your Amazon and
your Twitch account as you have to do
for us to get credit from your Amazon
Prime account link to your Twitch
account same time same place
tomorrow surf up [__] you've
been listening to the Tony Michaels
podcast podcast in your face commentary
of current events in political news no
rules No Boundaries I think we've made
that perfectly clear we hope you enjoyed
the show and we'll be back soon in the
meantime follow Tony on social media at
the Tony Michaels and until next time
raise a fist and repeat after
me [__] them [__]
[Music]
them
Murphy's mebor head ass
speaking
thank you that will be all God damn it
that's not
all I actually think Republicans should
embrace this so to think of Republic is
trying to shimmy away and shy away from
the whole narrative that we're white
Christian nationalists no that's what
the Republican Party should be we should
try to go back to our traditional Roots
America is a white CHR Chris nation and
it's okay that we want to maintain that
Nation we want to maintain what the
country was founded on let's Embrace
this let's stop letting the left attack
us embrace the attacks they always call
us racist fine I'm racist call me that
it's fine fine I'm racist fine I'm
racist fine I'm
racist